hi everyone I am Shaggy was me and I'm
gonna be tasting a couple of different
patties to see if New York patties
actually much of the Jamaican patties
but those of you have never had a party
there are certain things you have to
look for first of all the me it has to
be seasoned right it can't be too much
meat and nothing of flick and the carpet
too much plate got nothing of me I've
never seen this before
it's got pepperoni cheese I've never had
a pizza party in Jamaica I love a party
that out that I find very good in
Jamaica that I started the evil laughter
is soy then somebody telling me that so
I make it worse stop eats I party lot
more flavorful but I can tell you after
but this is a damn heart attack I didn't
find it to be as nice as its sewn it out
of five what would you ring it I would
say 100 followers that's hot as a zero
[Music]
so this is one of the most popular no
you see this one nope they capture one
thing the flicks now whether or not them
get the meat part known is to be
determined this does not match up for
anything live out in Jamaica but this
tastes better than every single one of
the night you give it I give this on the
floor I don't think there's enough you
might give me an America that I might
eat that one bi five
just a bias Jimmy I'm sorry
[Music]